[Music]
their work has been relentless
now nhs staff have demands of their own
across the country they took to the
streets to say this
[Music]
the message to the prime minister and
his new health secretary
loud and clear my message is please do
rethink your
priorities but if you don't we're not
we're not going to go away quietly and
we're not going to let
you get away with it i've worked in the
nhs since 1982 i've never known a period
when our staff are so exhausted
so demoralized so badly led by the
government so let down
and underpaid you've said that you love
the nhs
and yet you've insulted the workers the
million workers by
only offering one percent which is
effectively a pay cut with inflation
it's simple isn't it helpful the
pandemic has made their work
personal jordan rivera and her team
lost three of their colleagues to covid
including dr abdul mabad chowdhury who'd
warned of a lack of protective equipment
it's like the most heartbreaking
heartbreaking
thing especially knowing that um he'd
just done that appeal
um for proper ppe and there have been
times when
we didn't have the things that we needed
and i know the hospital was
really doing everything they could you
know it's not their fault
um but when you have to appeal to
to local schools to give us their
science goggles
you know it's it's it was just terrible
terrible situation today is the first
step in a chain
of action for justice for our nhs at
this rally in nottingham we met maggie
who questions whether the job is still
worth the pay rise they've been offered
for the government to just offer a one
percent
and we basically put our lives on the
line you know for the last year
it's just it's just galling a real real
kick in the teeth
i'm a single mom i know i've still got
my car payments to make
still got a mortgage to try and keep up
if i can
and you know i know i've been a nurse in
the nhs for 32 years
i have considered quitting a department
of health spokesperson
says the government has agreed to a pay
uplift for nhs staff
at a time when pay-up lifts have been
paused across the public sector
to acknowledge the extraordinary effort
of nhs staff during the pandemic
but for these people the pay rise isn't
enough
as the nhs marks its 73rd birthday
its workers fear what the future has in
store
becky johnson sky news in nottingham